previously on seven days to die I will
be back and we'll make that four jump
and we'll get it good like if you ting
the more stuff you have in a building it
attracts zombies like produces either
light you're saying we should put it in
the garage or something mark we only
have one minute before [ __ ] goes
sideways well that's fun because I need
a minute to make this verge maybe we
should just place the forge in the
morning listen buddy some of us like to
play bold some of us like to play like a
pansy
it's ominous o'clock be careful my
friends be careful I'll close the door
guys oh holy jesus good god I didn't
know it'd be like that I'm gonna block
off the stairs just for like extra good
measure should we should we open up the
window so we can shoot Adam or something
I have to find them yeah I'll try to
find I'll follow oh sorry that's okay
what are you coming out here just be
real careful hopping up because if you
fall off they're gonna eat your soul
I've got an angle on one of them Jesus
he's down for good yeah oh you can zoom
in with your bow yeah if you hold right
click you can like zoom a little bit are
they inside the house yet wait how's it
looking wait what I don't see him at the
staircase yet oh yeah they're in the
house okay come in alright mark have you
come over where I'm at we have an angle
on them on the stairs right now you got
that I'm gonna help
Wade with his deal that's a lot of them
Wade yep
they are doing a lot of damage to things
head Shan the stairs alright I just
popped a head alright hey that's a
couple more on the stairs yeah another
one hit me Oh see god I mean it's only
midnight Oh God
wait what do you tell us it was gonna
get bad oh yeah wait what we're not
ready for this at all what have you been
leading us towards well I've got some
s'mores Girl Scout cookies and I'm just
gonna eat one of these and pretend my
friends don't exist well that's not how
we're gonna get through this
yeah wait we really need some teamwork
if we're gonna survive this I think it's
got chocolate and marshmallow wait
please
did anyone cook up those eggs in the in
the drinks cooler bro you got some bacon
and eggs all right I got a nice little
spot here if they come back I'm ready to
rock do you think I can go out to that
Forge and get that [ __ ] going again yeah
you think oh yeah I would definitely do
that I think that'd be fine well I'll
stand up on the roof here and watch you
die I mean help you are you dude [ __ ]
oh go I know that towards you sprint is
[Laughter]
even close the door behind you there's
not even a door on there okay all right
yeah it's not letting me oh I need tools
for it oh I need like a crucible oh wait
no sorry there's an option I think I was
just
I'm gonna go peepee I'll be right back
master chef Baba
it wasn't on is the thing the thing
wasn't on you have to turn it on guys
don't know if you knew that so I'm gonna
make forged iron that's not good
is it safe out are we good I think I
think it's fine yeah I think it was I'm
gonna go hunter I'm gonna go on the hunt
baby that sounds like a great idea
hunting a piggy piggies are good piggy
piggies give you twenty meat if you see
one get it okay come on oh we really
need more wood I think cuz the spikes
didn't help
we need more spikes yeah what we've been
correct yeah wait what were these spikes
supposed to do for us I think just
literally take the path that we walk up
yeah so we know we need to like close
ourselves in with spikes on the seventh
day we will have to close tonight that's
tonight yeah this is day six so it'll be
my thing it's the seventh night I think
it's tomorrow night 7:00 tomorrow right
okay okay okay we'll find out not dead
yet apparently I can make level two
stone axe I don't know what that means I
think it has more durability and it
might harvest more wood per hit oh it
would be useful oh my goodness okay then
I should make those for you period
can you level up again can you take the
next Perkin miner six clattering I'm not
there yet I have no points available oh
yeah start working down that tree if you
don't want to go down that tree no no no
no maybe then I will figure out what I'm
going to start putting points into I
guess I'm gonna take cooking and hunting
if there's hunting stuff I guess I'll go
with looting I'll just keep working on
looting bellows wait there's belt we had
bellows oh I haven't advanced bellows in
my in the shed by the stairs we do the
chest so there's 27 spike trip I wanted
to drop stuff off in your forage one
yeah I'm storing things in the cabinet
next to you here let me get you an axe
real quick if you can do it on the stone
spear to okay yeah I cannot do that
I looks okay um and you need the leather
there's a leather leather I've got
I can use that for no oh dude anyone
have ducked it oh no that needs 30 iron
screw that through that iron will not be
that hard to come by in a short amount
of time yeah now that I know I can start
smashing up the rocks that need it it's
raining again or wet
oh no I'm 62 percent umbrella [ __ ] oh
yeah it's really raining oh my god is
that bad for me I don't know hey I'm an
expert this game yeah that's kind of
what you advertised oh that's not good
Oh an iron arrow slit like something you
could fire through oh nice Oh weird oh I
can make buckshot oh [ __ ] we can make a
lot of stuff on this thing okay cool
I'll let that whoa that's more spikes
Wow who's making those I make them right
now but I'm out of wood again I can give
you 400 wood but that's oh my god I
found another snake all right Wade woods
on the front by the front porch okay oh
all right good on you snake that's got
six meats from that little snake dude
baby that's not so bad
nice snake I'm glad you exist snake I
take back all the mean things I said
about you all right I'm only 52 percent
umbrella I guess time all right kids
the more I say it the less funny it's
supposed to get what if it is tonight
that that's the bad night
now we're fine the wood is will be very
dead getting mad Iron Dog yeah we're
gonna need a lot of iron because these
tools each require 30 forged iron so if
we're all gonna have at least one
pickaxe we need 90 Jesus all right well
I just got a hundred and five minor
walkway from like one deposit so dump er
in the Forge I'm when I when I get back
hopefully with some delicious food I'm
hunting a coyote Bros play in stone I
was just told if we make clay in stone
we can make cobblestone but we've
replaced like our wood with that cool
I've got clay going in here I'm just
gonna take the sand I've got in now and
then pop in this iron yeah I guess we
could put stone
there I'm about to level up I'm about to
get another point and miner nice thank
you
whoopsies for the cobblestone we don't
need to use the forward we just need
clay and stone oh okay well I put stone
in there anyway so tough deal with it
how are we doing on liquids I feel like
we need I have seven water bottles on me
oh yeah I have an empty water bottles on
me but like I've got something seven
water yes i leveled should I get miner
69er next or yeah you know it actually
miner 69 er yeah there we go
stone axe level 3 nice dude thanks nice
nice thank you thank you
Wow hey the engineers drop [ __ ] Oh what
351 Casino tokens 43 bullets
dude this engineer was loaded how did he
die I mean oh god he only had one coin
weird I'm gonna put all my four G rocky
bits down by the Forge I guess this
cabinets full so I'm gonna put it just
[ __ ] for you in this trash pile market
it's gonna build a chest alright it's in
the trash pot okay well I'm gonna build
the chest anyway so alright I thought
there'd be another plane flying overhead
today it's supposed to be every three
days for the planes yeah I don't know if
only someone had found it huh Oh guys
I'm gonna baby you're growing a baby
that's plane a little baby I don't like
that it's gonna grow a beautiful big boy
okay where's the trash pile oh the trash
pounced
well there's Liggins ghats Springs
beautiful yeah there's a jammed secured
storage chests so if that's yours Bob
yeah Bob made a mr. ethem locket oh I
didn't unlock it
sorry sorry I'll come back it's okay jar
of honey who put it charm huh
down here possibly be I was just trying
to empty out my inventory a little bit I
got a little frantic it's unlocked now
mark thank you all right oh that's
schematic I like the sound of that Oh
fun guys 2120
yeah I'll get closer to the house wait I
don't know where exactly how far you are
but I'm right next to the house
maybe we should block ourselves in this
night just in case maybe okay I'm going
in the irons cooking overnight oh god oh
god oh god I'm scared
I mean it's not blood man okay it would
you would literally be like blame the
other night I wouldn't worry about it
right now I would save them we need
we're gonna need them for tonight okay
look even if they get in tonight like
it's gonna be manageable I'm gonna take
my spot on the roof again so I can shoot
in at the stairs okay we have the spare
bacon and eggs upstairs still there in
the cooler on the way up in the coolers
reach on in grab yourself a douche some
what I call food douche why do you call
it douche my spin on nosh you know it
shouldn't be just grab some juice that's
what I'm saying grab some straps do
don't think that's a good name for it
hey who made it who gets to name it I
think the answer to both you'll find is
the same Oh God Mountain douche Code Red
gun tears why did why were there no
zombies tonight whereas before there was
a bajillion well we killed a mini Ward
before we came in which I think kept
someone from attacking there's like one
little zombie off to the west just Oh
looking at hero
I'll get your asses in here I got a low
cream though you want create some aloe
cream if you want it take my cream one
trade you all good trade good trade good
trade fool I'm outside by the way no not
no no everything's fine there's nothing
out here
is anybody want an iron pickaxe I will
take it since I'll be out hunting or one
other and I can use it together if you
have one more leather I can oh no these
forty iron oh my god
I can do it I get worried about it d/f
are you know I bet I can scavenge this
leather duster down into leather if you
really need it I mean I don't need to
need it but if you want to go ahead sure
we don't really need the duster so I'll
just go ahead and salvage it I guess
it's gonna give me thirteen leather what
damn are you down at the forge marks how
are your doing yes I am okay I'll bring
you this leather
the spikes I forgot about the spikes
we're in danger my friend I got this
jump I'll make you a pickaxe I've got so
many things in line before thee just
crafting a thousand things right I need
a bandage okay here we go
iron pickaxe it's gonna be three minutes
and thirty seconds that's fine I'm not
going anywhere anyway well it's for now
just you know what you come back you'll
you'll get it tonight that's where it'll
be waiting oh yeah I'm gonna go south on
my hunt today my hunt my hunt the hunt
begins
sounds like a blood-borne yeah finish
that game I never played that game
either great game I love that game it's
too hard I mean I think it's just hard
enough how am I supposed to do a media
review of it if it's that hard hooters
unite Oh iron pickaxe devastates rocks
nice it's probably not a good thing that
we're gonna have to survive day seven
without guns well I got bows and arrows
bro how much how hard can it be
yeah we got bullets how do we not have
guns it's hot what hot mark you all
right there
my friends getting shared XP it's good I
hear a snake approaching my presence
holy [ __ ] what are you are you a friend
what are you doing here I'm working my
way to get wood and also toward the town
trying to find guns and trying to not
you were a snake I'm so disappointed no
I'm not floppity yet I had a beanie baby
named floppity once it was a bunny
makes sense I had hoppity hippity and
floppity thanks it or it does check out
that's good story chainsaw steel pickaxe
I just found a steel pickaxe Wow oh I
fell in a hole oh my god oh what the
hell oh yeah I fell somewhere I'm oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh I got scary
scary scary scary scary scary get up oh
my god he jumps holy crap dude if we can
fix up a school bus and drive an
overpair kit I found a repair kit to
repair kits are really nice that's how
you repair your guns and [ __ ] you feel
pickaxe probably damn okay I found some
underground wine cellar with beverage
coolers lots of water lots of jars damn
down jumping I learned how to jump o
Kristi thanks man
and I guess gasoline is not a terrible
thing to hear Oh what I found a forged
schematic god damn it
Oh wrench schematic though mark I might
give you these recipes because you're
gonna be crafting all this stuff right
uh-huh
you're kind of our craft of 16 repair
kits 16 times the repair kits that I had
previously oh my god an armor Viking
just rained from the sky
I found grenades dude this house is like
the house I'm gonna be coming back real
slow I'm gonna be super encumbered did
you get loot thoughts my arrow whoa whoa
whoa oh my god get out get up get up oh
my god Jesus Christ where did you come
from
my aim is so bad I'm hitting a zombie
I'm not even aiming at that's sad oh my
god oh my frickin hell God we're all
having a good how far away can you hear
me from I'm dead Oh No oh [ __ ] oh where
did you one is flying it's flying it's
fine let's hope it's flying
white barrels oh you guys see out day
seven is red that's how we know yeah
cool we're not gonna be [ __ ] it's
gonna be fine dude
fine yeah that's the weapons bag I ran
into a cactus that's how you do now
we're basically set up
working stiff sealed shipping crate I
did fine once you want wearin shut-ins a
trigger plate iron pickaxe
and to lead car batteries generator but
nice nice nice nice nice nice I'm being
an idiot don't worry all right long as
we're all do that one hit ko this dude
nice i found a level three blunderbuss
oh airplane nailed him come on drop it
drop it drop it drop it right over yeah
that's over you I can if you can find it
I I will
it looks like it's dropping right over
whoever yellow is is that means you
bought it oh it's not gonna land on that
roof is it
no they suelen just in front right by
the tree there is like two or three
zombies in the front yard to be careful
okay oh my god scares the crap outta me
yeah if you go straight like
south-southwest you'll see it's the big
square looking building
thus Wiggins soon yes Wiggins here house
no point of that all right I gotta get
out of here
I am so encumbered right now I have
three grenades
oh no oh is that good or bad no probably
oh my god oh my god oh my god I'm dead
I'm dead I'm so dead guys guys I'm so
dead
don't guys I'm so dead oh I'm so dead
I'm so the weights only in places don't
alright here we go
this is last my last stand guys holy
[ __ ] oh my god go back outside [ __ ]
home runs home runs come on
Oh we'll give me one more sweet home run
fall over oh my god fall over to my
breakdown this chemistry station I got
the schematic off that chemistry station
in that building so I don't know not die
I lived good job that was horrifying
oh boy I'm making friends ammo pile oh
my god there's so much good stuff this
is like the best house I think it was
that broken girl my god I'm so
encumbered right now I am also
unbelievably in down dummy thick mark
slow at the moment yep can I make myself
some arrows oh my god an ak-47 a
double-barreled shotgun Jesus Christ
dude this house is the house there's a
gun safe in here I do not have a
lockpick just so you guys know there's
AG oh my god - double-barreled schematic
I'm heading back I've got an aka a
double-barreled shotgun this schematic
for an hunting rifle
mark what the hell dude this house had
everything I just got to make it back
I'm hot
is that what's happening right now I
have a sad son next to me it's hot it's
hot out here that's what that means is
hot yeah I went out to get rocks and I
came I'm coming back with guns and gun
schematics
you did good yeah I did good guys I did
real good
I can we just what is that just like
frozen
I think lightning yeah yeah yeah oh my
god um I ran out of spike traps right
here so this back corner is not fully
spiked off nor is the door the doors
have so I have some more I know that's
um I dropped my would not complete
corners out
and then we'll at the wall off the
entrances as well we have three hours to
do it which is unfortunate but is what
it is it'll be safe am
what are you doing fam fam is good oh my
god I made it back I also put a bunch of
bullets up here in my chest we have 61
76 to 172 9 mil at some shotgun shells I
don't know what all we have there's a
there's a double-barrel shotgun up for
grabs in my chest with ammo I'll take
that 762 ammo
it's uh panting rifle I'll take I'll
take half of it there's thirty one left
for you yeah we have 45 45 minutes
someone grab this double-barreled
where's it at it's in my chest mark I've
got 24 shots with it you can take some
more for your gun okay mark I don't know
if you can use this for your gun I'm
gonna drop it on the ground just in case
shotgun shells freeze don't you grab the
shotgun all of a sudden on day seven
we're just started finding good stuff I
cannot use the bandolier with mine just
okay I'll put it I'm not sure what guns
it's good for it might be the hunting
rifle I would think with oh I'll check
it out where'd you put it right here
yeah it's in there oh that sounds bad
well this goes into armor it doesn't go
it goes into armor that's why oh that
makes sense okay all right I hear I'll
have armor on do you have armor own I
have some armor oh yeah Bob this will be
good for you to feed on shotgun reload
shotguns faster be good I didn't like
that so many I can't see I can't see him
did they break it down there down there
on our feet
oh man as soon as the light goes away
anything all torch for you
dead dead are they coming from
there's a whole bunch of back here still
got that one okay they're dying on the
spikes thank God
oh hey yeah 1/4 of them ready broken
through a bunch of the spikes right down
the middle yeah that they're on the
patio now there's some going around the
west side going for our 420 breaking in
there there's a whole bunch trying to
break into the back door that's going to
be problem holy they're breaking in the
door inside they're breaking in the door
inside okay coming and coming
whoa they're in they came through the
wall here yeah they did I got shotgun
do we have light in here we got a light
we're good oh [ __ ]
alright you guys are there you guys you
guys stay there I'm gonna take the roof
spot okay so what just reloading you got
that one shrine man
now finally I try to put down what's
done at you guys I'm sorry
more more MORE
the big one-oh more coming from my side
out here there's no dog reload you try
to put the stupid cube down let me their
corpses are forbidding it I'm infected I
defect in 66 two guys six bullets left
almost out trying to make an account
I've got 35 shells left over here so as
long as you can hold the line yep
bullets right here mark okay
I'm stuck where I don't see him
dog head okay I think they're getting
caught on their own corpses at this
point yeah looks like it
all right is that it damn okay
damn you were not joking that was a lot
that's the easiest horde night we're
gonna have oh my god can you imagine if
we hadn't found those guns last minute
oh my god I got so much stuff on the
very last day like the moment before
yeah I'm gonna sneak out inside looking
around that seems to a guy oh wow good
job everybody
booth yikes fun feel like we had that
pretty well in hand
[Music]